Farming has been a central part of America since its founding.
In the 19th century, homesteaders settled the American West.
Today, America boasts 900 million acres of farmland, according to the USDA.
That's 40% of our land, and our farms provide food across the world.
In 2021, the government says U.S. farmers exported 177 billion dollars in products,...
…like soybeans, corn, beef, and pork.
According to the Department of Agriculture,...
…American citizens own 97% of privately held farmland...
…and forest in the United States.
Some say U.S. farms are a global asset that should be shared.
Bloomberg columnist, Adam Minter, wrote this in August,...
"Food security is enhanced by outsiders who seek economic opportunity in farm country.
They should be welcomed."
Recently though, the 3% of farmland owned by foreigners has attracted controversy,...
…specifically a focus on China.
Lacking farmland, China has struggled to secure food for its 1.4 billion citizens.
Just recently in August, four Chinese government departments warned a drought,...
…posed a severe threat to the autumn harvest.
That has driven overseas investments in food, ...
…including the purchase of Virginia based pork producer, Smithfield Foods...
...and partnership with Growmark, a grain logistics firm.
Chinese companies own about a fifth of 1% of American agricultural land per USDA data,...
…but some lawmakers say Chinese firms shouldn't own American farmland at all.
America cannot allow China to control our food supply.
And the president and the Congress...
…should end all farm subsidies for land owned by foreign nationals.